c'est l'heure tout de suite de notre
second débat consacré à la réforme de la
police judiciaire qui prévoit de placer
tous les services de police d'un
département sur l'autorité d'un
directeur lui-même dépendant du préfet
est-ce la fin de la PJ alors que
Frédéric Vaud le grand patron des
policiers était entendu aujourd'hui
devant la mission d'information du Sénat
on va voir ce qui pourrait changer
d'abord grâce à ce reportage dans l'Oise
c'est l'un des 8 départements où la
nouvelle organisation est testée Flora
sauvage
le département de l'Oise teste depuis le
1er mars la nouvelle organisation de la
police nationale la réforme prévoit de
regrouper au niveau de départemental
tous les services de police et de les
placer sous l'autorité d'un chef unique
le directeur départemental de la police
nationale dépendant directement du
préfet messieurs dames bonjour là vous
avez les bureaux des enquêteurs bonjour
pour le patron de la sécurité publique
de l'Oise cette réorganisation est
nécessaire on a des services qui parfois
travaillent sur les mêmes objectifs qui
viennent en confrontation les uns envers
les autres et tout ça manque
singulièrement de cohérence et de
fluidité donc l'idée de la réforme qui
est issue du livre blanc de la sécurité
surtout des travaux du Beauvau de la
sécurité et de repenser l'organisation
judiciaire actuellement les 5000
enquêteurs de la police judiciaire
dépendent d'une direction unique avec
des moyens spécifiques pour traiter les
affaires plus complexe avec la réforme
ils craignent de perdre leur spécificité
on dépendra avec cette réforme d'un
directeur départemental de la police
nationale qui dépendra lui-même
directement du préfet qui sera son
unique interlocuteur donc il est
quasiment certain que le directeur
départemental de la police nationale ne
consacrera pas ses effectifs à traiter
le haut du spectre de la criminalité qui
indiffère
globalement
les citoyens mais qu'il aura à cœur de
résoudre toute la petite et moyen de
délinquance qui pourrit la vie sur son
département en renforçant les effectifs
de la sécurité publique en leur
apportant le savoir-faire de l'APJ cette
réforme vise aussi à améliorer la
qualité des procédures qui laissent
parfois à désirer selon ce professeur de
droit pénal on a recruté massivement
pour compenser le déficit de 10000
fonctionnaires qui avaient été supprimés
sous Nicolas Sarkozy pour recruter
massivement
on a baissé le niveau de sorte que
aujourd'hui les procédures effectuées
par la sécurité publique ne sont pas
nécessairement d'une très grande qualité
finissent donc par être annulées par les
magistrats on va déplacer les
fonctionnaires qui sont en charge de ces
affaires complexes et qui ont donc un
temps maintenant réduit pour enquêter au
niveau local où ils vont devoir suppléer
les carences des des fonctionnaires de
sécurité publique pour assurer les
fonctionnaires de l'APJ le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin assure que
des aménagements pourront être apportés
à la réforme qu'il souhaite mettre en
place courant 2023 de son côté la
commission des Lois du Sénat a créé une
mission d'information pour examiner
l'opportunité d'une telle réorganisation
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour débattre sourds cette
réforme de la police judiciaire Camille
chaise bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
porte-parole du ministère de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer David le Bart bonsoir
bienvenue à secrétaire général du
syndicat des commissaires de la police
nationale une ça fait bloqué un bon
soirée bienvenue au grand reporter
indépendant spécialisé dans les yeux de
la police banditisme et du renseignement
et auteur de c'était la PJ le temps béni
des flics livre publiés aux éditions
fayards avec nous également en duplex en
visioconférence qui me reflète qui est
présidente du Syndicat de la
magistrature bonsoir à vous et Mathieu
croissanto évidemment est resté à mes
côtés peut-être un premier retour
d'expérience avec vous qu'à Michel sur
ces tests dans 8 départements qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui en revient alors les
tests ont déjà commencé dans les
départements d'outre-mer parce qu'il y
avait des moyens plus limités donc assez
rapidement il y a maintenant plusieurs
mois on a rassemblé autour d'un
directeur unique ça a bien fonctionné en
outre-mer puis trois départements tests
en métropole dans l'Hexagone puis 5
nouveaux et globalement comme l'a dit
mon collègue commissaire dans l'Oise on
a vu des rapprochements on a vu des
synergies politiques des mises en commun
de moyens et des services fluidité qui
dialoguaient pas suffisamment c'est ça
alors pas suffisamment on avait parfois
une guerre un petit peu entre services
ou un partage d'informations qui n'était
pas complètement efficace donc ça a
forcé à rapprocher en droit constant
parce que rien n'a évolué c'est
seulement par plus de coordination et
des moyens mutualisés et donc ça a bien
marché dans l'Oise où il y avait quand
même on l'a vu la question de l'aéroport
de Beauvais avec la police aux
frontières la PJ la criminalité
organisée dans l'Oise qui est
particulièrement importante et de temps
en temps la Sécurité publique a pu
donner des informations des moyens la
police judiciaire pour ensemble pouvoir
résoudre assez rapidement des enquêtes
donc on a vu cet exemple il y a eu la
Savoie par exemple avec une
problématique
transfrontalière avec avec l'Italie qui
a qui a rendu aussi comme ça des des
leviers de coordination intéressant donc
on a plusieurs exemples où ça marche
bien d'où l'idée maintenant de passer la
vitesse supérieure et de pouvoir en 2023
pouvoir généraliser cette réforme qui
n'est pas je m'excuse juste qui n'est
pas une réforme de la police judiciaire
le renseignement l'investigation la
police judiciaire l'ordre public la
police aux frontières en l'occurrence
notre débat on a décidé de le centrer
sur le le l'avenir de la de l'APJ David
lears est-ce que vous craignez une
disparition de la PJ alors je la crains
mais pour que ça n'arrive pas il faut
s'opposer à ce que ça risque d'arriver
et ça n'est pas le cas le but c'est ce
qu'a dit qu'à Michel c'est pas de
réformer la police judiciaire ou de la
faire disparaître et puis si on a qui
ont cette intention il faut aussi
opposer le but c'est de réorganiser la
police ça c'est l'intitulé exacte et
c'est de faire en sorte il y a deux
objectifs à atteindre c'est de ni
d'humilier ou de rabaisser les uns ni de
donner de faux espoirs aux autres c'est
quoi la réorganisation de la police
nationale c'est d'essayer de tirer le
meilleur des effectifs et des moyens et
des structures pour se décloisonner en
gardant les spécialités ce qu'on sait
faire on le fait très bien dans la
police judiciaire et ne pas faire croire
parce que ça c'est un quelque chose
qu'il faut démonter sur ce plateau que
le gros de la délinquance de masse qui
sature les services de sécurité publique
et ben on va étaler un petit peu pour en
donner à l'APJ pour qui finalement se
retrouve tiré par le bas et ne puisse
plus faire leur cœur de métier c'est pas
ça l'objectif et s'il y en a qui ont
cette idée là il faut aussi opposer donc
ça veut dire que aujourd'hui tel que
vous la voyez apparaître vous êtes quoi
en attente opposé à la réforme pas
forcément opposé c'est quoi non mais je
vais vous répondre très clairement moi
je représente les commissaires de police
les positions puis j'en ai écrit de
certaines moi je suis très favorable à
réfléchir à ce qui est dans les formes
par filière déjà j'avais dit au ministre
au congrès du syndicat des commissaires
il y a une erreur sémantique c'était de
parler de la réforme des départements la
réforme des ddpn toutes les missions de
police ne peuvent pas rentrer dans le
cocon départemental pourquoi des
questions de sensibilité des questions
de compétences territoriales et puis moi
c'est sûrement au niveau du syndicat je
ne crois pas un chef zonal sans troupes
ça c'est un premier point et le deuxième
point c'est très important c'est que
cette réforme là elle doit être dans
l'intérêt du citoyen et c'est de savoir
quoi faire c'est pourquoi faire la
réforme c'est pour lutter contre la
haute criminalité c'est pour donner des
meilleures réponses citoyens et c'est la
doctrine qui va permettre d'appliquer
les bons organigrammes et de construire
la bonne police de demain donc c'est une
réflexion de fond alors on va écouter
maintenant Frédéric Ploquin là-dessus
j'obtiens un départementalisation on va
évidemment y revenir en détail et puis
effectivement de quel crime et de quel
délit la police judiciaire va s'occuper
c'est une vraie question centrale les
policiers les commissaires que vous
croisez en ce moment ils sont dans quel
état d'esprit avec avec cette réforme
est-ce qu'ils ont peur est-ce que est-ce
qu'ils sont bien mal informés c'est quoi
votre tour c'est une bonne question
c'est vrai qu'en dehors de toutes les
questions de réforme de structure moi je
m'intéresse beaucoup à l'humain et
j'écoute beaucoup les policiers et quand
on les écoute en termes de police
judiciaire bon d'abord c'est une maison
très ancienne un peu les judiciaire qui
a qui a plus de 100 ans parce qu'elle
remonte à 1900-1905 c'est une maison qui
a une culture qui a ses légendes qui a
ses bonnes belles et noir légende aussi
c'est une maison qui a eu ces héros
c'est une maison qui en fait je pense
que qu'aujourd'hui quel que soit le
ministre justement commencé par
respecter cette culture cette cette
maison ce métier là parce que pour une
fois qu'on a des policiers qui en gros
sont bien leur peau dans leur basket et
qui disent nous on fait un métier on
veut le défendre je pense qu'il faut les
écouter les défendre tellement on a de
policiers qui justement ont perdu un peu
le sens de leur métier donc là
aujourd'hui on a quoi on a dit que les
commissaires ou les agents de police
judiciaires ils ont ils sont un peu
moins touchés par ce blues du policier
je pense que non je pense que le ceux
qui sont en police judiciaire ils sont
pas très nombreux ils sont 5000 5000
5300 je crois c'est-à-dire que c'est en
fait c'est une goutte d'eau dans la
police nationale la police judiciaire la
police la sécurité publique c'est plus
de c'est entre 65 et 70 000 personnes là
on a 5500 personnes qui sont accrochées
à leur histoire et qui depuis au moins
20 ans c'est pas nouveau d'aujourd'hui
me disent régulièrement mais on va
disparaître on va nous avaler à chaque
fois qu'il y a des réformes je me
souviens qu'en 1998 c'était un ministre
de gauche événement qui avait réformé la
préfecture de police de Paris et il
avait cassé enfin il avait supprimé les
commissariats de police qui étaient des
commissaires de police judiciaire à
Paris et il avait fondu c'est comme les
salades de police dans la sécurité
publique exactement quelque chose
d'assez similaire à ce qui pourrait se
faire au niveau national aujourd'hui et
à l'époque toute la toutes les policiers
de police judiciaires étaient vend
debout et on dit en gros voilà
Jean-Pierre Chevènement Philippe
maçonniste et le préfet de l'époque sont
les fossoyeurs de la police judiciaire
donc cette impression qu'ils ont en
police judiciaire de disparaître de
mourir bientôt en fait elle dure depuis
ce sont des écorchés vifs ce sont des
gens qui sont et puis qui défendent et
qui défendent vraiment leur boutique
donc aujourd'hui effectivement quand
vous les voyez on a l'impression que à
chaque fois qu'on leur parle leur monde
s'écroule leur monde va s'écrouler après
bon ça c'est sur le plan humain après
ils ont des arguments c'est vrai que du
point de vue politique on a l'impression
que ce qui compte le plus c'est la
petite et moyen de délinquance qui
frappe le plus de citoyens d'accord donc
le politique place Beauvau ou ailleurs
ou dans les préfectures se disent il
faut traiter cette petite délinquance or
e en police judiciaires ils traitent
plutôt il faut le dire le haut du
spectre c'est à dire la criminalité
organisée et les policiers qui
travaillent en police du cercle comme
moi qui travaille sur ces sujets savent
très bien aujourd'hui que l'un des
enjeux majeurs de sécurité sur les 20
ans qui viennent c'est l'explosion de la
criminalité organisée tout autant
effectivement la petite criminalité
dérange au quotidien tous nos citoyens
on est d'accord mais l'explosion de la
criminalité organisée regardez ce qui se
passe en Belgique aujourd'hui vous avez
des groupes criminels qui ont failli
passer à l'acte et assassiné sans
prendre à la vie du ministre de la
justice c'est-à-dire qu'en gros en
Belgique on a des faits qui ce qui était
à deux doigts de se produire qui nous
font penser quasiment la Colombie on
n'est pas en colombien en France mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que les gros
poissons c'est ce qui est aussi fait de
la délinquance du quotidien je pense au
stupe
ça touche tous les spectres
effectivement si on veut lutter contre
les stupéfiants il faut il faut aller du
haut en bas on est parfaitement d'accord
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que si on
fond c'est ça qui nous disent
aujourd'hui les policiers de police
judiciaires si vous faites disparaître
cette maison avec ses spécialités avec
ce que vous faites disparaître un
savoir-faire et vous allez vous
retrouver avec le avec une explosion du
criminel et donc personne ne se voit ce
que disait David une question à mon avis
ça rejoint ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure et ça va vraiment être au cœur
de notre débat c'est à dire que est-ce
que avec une nouvelle organisation la
police judiciaire va finalement avoir
plus de moyens pour être plus efficace
contre le crime organisé ou est-ce qu'au
contraire on va la tirer un peu vers le
bas vers la petite de la Corse je vous
propose à ce moment du débat pour bien
comprendre cette réforme grâce à
alexandre Poussin on va on va voir
comment s'organise actuellement
Alexandre la police nationale et
précisément la police judiciaire oui
Thomas alors pour bien comprendre on va
d'abord regarder l'architecture de la
police nationale au sommet le ministère
de l'Intérieur la direction générale et
puis en dessous des directions centrales
bien séparées peut-être des maisons
comme vous dites avec la direction
centrale de la sécurité publique la
direction centrale de la police aux
frontières et puis la direction centrale
de la police Jud cette division qui nous
intéresse et qui fonctionne finalement
comme un silo de manière assez
indépendante dans cette direction de la
police judiciaire et bien au niveau
national il y a les services centraux
qui gèrent les crimes graves complexes
avec chaque service qui finalement est
organisé en fonction du type d'affaires
il y a le terrorisme le crime organisé
la cybercriminalité le trafic de
stupéfiant et puis à l'échelon
territoriale l'APJ est piloté par des
directions réparties en zone des
directions zonale par exemple la
direction du sud-est de la France et
puis ensuite quand on descend encore au
niveau départemental vous avez les
policiers enquêteurs de la SDPJ le
service départemental de la police
judiciaire qui travaille encore de
manière assez autonome par rapport aux
autres services de police et que peut
changer la réforme à cette organisation
alors pas grand chose au niveau national
les différentes directions centrales de
la police sont maintenus c'est vraiment
au niveau départemental que ça va
changer puisque cette réforme elle
prévoit de réunir sous une même
Direction Départementale les différentes
divisions de la police la sécurité
publique la PAF la police aux frontières
le renseignement et puis l'investigation
cela veut dire concrètement et bien que
les enquêteurs de la PJ devront rendre
des comptes à ce futur directeur
départemental de la police nationale qui
sera en lien avec le préfet et notamment
ce point qui pose problème mais on le
rappelle pour bien comprendre et bien
dans une enquête l'agent de la police
judiciaire reste bien sous l'autorité de
la justice c'est-à-dire soit le
procureur soit le juge d'instruction
merci Alexandre justement je me tourne
vers Kim reflet à ce moment du débat le
Syndicat de la magistrature s'oppose à
cette réforme de la police judiciaire
est-ce que c'est parce que vous avez une
certaine façon peur de perdre votre
autorité sur sur les effectifs au
bénéfice du préfet finalement
alors on s'oppose pour plusieurs raisons
effectivement à cette réforme
principalement on pense que le
la réforme de la police judiciaire va
nous faire perdre en fait
la disposition d'un service d'enquête
voilà d'investigation très bien informé
un service d'investigation très
spécifique dont on a besoin sur les juge
d'instruction principalement ont besoin
sur le haut du spectre de la criminalité
ce dont on a parlé et donc le fait de en
fait le fait de faire passer la police
judiciaire sous le commandement unique
du directeur départemental de la police
nationale va en fait amener à selon nous
à une mutualisation des effectifs de
police judiciaire avec ceux de la
sécurité publique donc on nous explique
que l'idée c'est pas du tout ça c'est
notamment de tirer les effectifs de
sécurité publique vers le haut en
faisant bénéficier assez policiers de
l'expertise des policiers de police
judiciaires mais nous on pense que c'est
le contraire qui va se passer il y a pas
de d'expérience de mutualisation
d'effectifs de manière générale qui se
terminent par qui ne se termine par un
appauvrissement généralisé un des
effectifs donc ont vraiment on a peur de
ça les juges d'instruction craignent de
ne plus pouvoir disposer comme ils le
souhaitent de ses enquêteurs d'élite
voilà de ces services d'enquête dont ils
ont besoin pour mener leurs instructions
et puis il y a aussi la question du
ressort géographique dont on n'a pas
parlé mais revenir voilà une police
judiciaire départementale avec un
ressort géographique limité ça ne ça ne
correspond pas du tout à l'évolution de
la criminalité telle qu'elle est
constatée par les professionnels et
d'ailleurs ça correspond pas non plus à
l'évolution de nos organisations c'est à
dire à la mise en place de juridiction
interrégionales par exemple ou
l'organisation qui existe dans la dans
la gendarmerie donc qui est plutôt
d'élargir
[Musique]
en expérimentation qui sont pas
forcément ceux que kamichèse nous
donnait tout à l'heure je vais vous
redonner la parole évidemment un peu
plus tard qui me refait
n'ayez pas peur ça je reviendrai vers
vous forcément mais je voudrais qu'on
entende une réaction du ministre de
l'Intérieur forcément Gérald Darmanin et
ça rejoint ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sur finalement le nombre
d'effectifs qui pourraient être
mobilisés pour des enquêtes de police
judiciaire on écoute le ministre il
s'agit de lutter pour la police
judiciaire soit plus forte elle parle se
passera de 5000 à 20 000 agents et de
mieux avoir des taux de lucidité
d'illustration plus efficaces plus
nombreux ce qu'ils ont tendance à
baisser évidemment nous le devons à nos
concitoyens alors il y a deux éléments
dans ce que vient de dire géralda marnin
il y a le le les moyens en humain et
puis le taux d'élucidation des crimes
dédiés on y reviendra tout à l'heure
Camille chaise sur les moyens et là on
est vraiment au cœur de l'efficacité ou
non de cette réforme quand on dit on va
passer de 5000 à 20 000 agents comment
ça va se mettre en place et comment
avoir la certitude peut effectivement
ils seront comment je peux dire ça
utiliser pour les enquêtes les plus
importantes alors ce qu'il faut bien
voir c'est que pour le moment ces
enquêteurs ils sont dispatchés dans
différentes directions avec différents
chefs là l'idée c'est vraiment de créer
une filière c'est à dire du de la
délinquance la plus générale sur les
territoires à la délinquance la plus
spécialisée la criminalité la plus
organisée la plus spécifique arrivé à
avoir des parcours de carrière pour les
les officiers de police judiciaire qui
pourront au fur et à mesure monter en
expertise monter en expérience pouvoir
se spécialiser pour le moment on a ces
5000 enquêteurs de la police judiciaire
qui a une identité forte qui est
reconnue qui est spécialisée qui sont
des très grands professionnels et l'idée
c'est qu'ils puissent aussi faire
bénéficier de leur expérience des des
services de sécurité publique qui
parfois ont d'autres compétences par
exemple si je reprends la situation dans
l'Oise le directeur départemental que
j'avais au téléphone il y a quelques
jours m'expliquait que récemment ils ont
résolu une affaire grâce à cette
connexion entre la police judiciaire et
les enquêteurs de la Sûreté urbaine et
de la la BAC parce que ils avaient des
informations terrain et une connaissance
terrain que la police judiciaire n'avait
peut-être pas et en connectant les deux
l'expertise des enquêteurs et la
connaissance des reins des terrains ça a
permis de résoudre une enquête
stupéfiant à remettre etc donc on voit
bien que c'est que cette coordination on
pourrait le faire à droit constant c'est
ce que les expérimentations fait mais
c'est encore mieux de d'avoir des textes
qui l'encadrent et qui le rendent
systématique on doit ça à nos
concitoyens pour que ce soit plus
efficace on a malgré tout des moyens
limités des moyens humains qui sont
importants mais limités des moyens
financiers malgré tout limité il faut
parfois mettre ça en commun pour
résoudre plus rapidement certaines
enquêtes comment vous vous imaginez
avoir la garantie que on passe de 5 à 20
000 d'abord si vous me permettez
j'aimerais reprendre ce qu'a dit qui me
refait parce que c'est un des dangers de
la réforme il n'y a pas des policiers
d'élite et puis après des policiers bas
de gamme c'est pas Clémenceau contre
Pinot simple flic c'est très important
de préserver le savoir-faire de la PJ
c'est très important de cibler comment
lutte contre le crime organisé et là je
peux rejoindre certaines inquiétudes de
j'en ai fait part c'est la conception de
l'échelon territorial je l'ai dit en
préliminaire tout ne rentre pas
l'échelle départementale mais il faut
prendre conscience aussi que dans les
services du quotidien j'en faisais
partie on a des policiers qui traitent
d'affaires criminels et ce portefeuille
global d'affaires quand on a de
l'investigation à la PAF police aux
frontières en sécurité publique à la PJ
et même ailleurs d'ailleurs parce que
les CRS font aussi du judiciaire sur le
routier quand on raisonne on le fait
ensemble on se rassemble on met un chef
on met le chef au bon niveau mais chacun
garde ses prérogatives et ses missions
là on commence à mieux comprendre
l'intérêt ça veut dire que ça n'existe
pas aujourd'hui c'est à dire que quand
on dit attention organisation en silo
c'est pas suffisamment non mais il faut
en plus admettre que on est en silo et
que parfois il y a des silos qui
fonctionnent mieux que d'autres en
fonction des humains mais il faut que ce
soit les structures qui permettent de
mieux fonctionner puis je vais vous dire
quand on raisonne 4 kilos 4 états
majeurs si demain il y a un silo bien
organisé en préservant les missions mais
un seul état-major on gagne aussi de la
ressource pour faire de la vraie mission
de police Mathieu c'est une question
idiote mais pour le téléspectateur quand
vous dites ça fonctionne en silo ça
compte on peut avoir deux services qui
travaillent sur la même sans le savoir
ou l'échange d'information n'est pas
suffisamment fluide ça fait des années
moi ça fait 12 ans que je suis dans la
police je pense ça fait 12 ans que
j'entends cette rengaine soit de la
guerre des polices soit un travail en
silo soit une information qui se passe
pas assez rapidement avec derrière des
pertes de chances malheureusement pour
les victimes donc c'est aussi ça ce
constat en le partage tous on a écrit
des livres blancs on a tous ces cris
beaucoup et de manière très concertée
d'ailleurs avec la société civile donc
je pense qu'on a le constat je pense que
l'objectif a atteindre on est pas loin
d'être tous d'accord ensemble dans la
maison police reste la manière d'y
arriver c'est à dire la conduite du
changement comment on mène cette
transformation parce qu'on sait que
cette réforme se fera que si elle
acceptée si elle est pas acceptée la
réforme ne marchera pas donc charge
maintenant au directeur de la police
d'être à l'écoute de réaliser les
conditions qui vont faire que cette
réforme sera acceptée et fonctionnera
mais à condition serait plus qu'un parce
que vous les retours que vous avez des
policiers que vous côtoyez c'est aussi
des plaintes contre le fait d'être trop
souvent derrière son ordinateur et pas
suffisamment sur le terrain c'est une
réalité c'est une autre question qui qui
est à l'étude depuis des mois qui
traînent et qui n'est pas résolu c'est
qu'effectivement les policiers qui
travaillent en police judiciaire se
plaignent en gros en gros ils auraient
ils préfèreraient comme leurs ancêtres
être plus souvent dans la rue
a priori que derrière leur ordinateur or
ils sont derrière l'ordinateur pour deux
raisons d'avoir parce qu'il y a des
moyens maintenant technologiques
d'enquête effectivement et
d'investigation qui avait pour autrefois
et que donc effectivement c'est le côté
positif parce qu'on suit des balises on
suit des choses comme ça qui traverse
les mers ou les frontières ça c'est une
chose mais de l'autre côté effectivement
il y a une mais ça c'est dit à tous les
niveaux de la police c'est pas seulement
la police judiciaire c'est à tous les
niveaux de la judiciarisation des faits
criminels les fonctionnaires se
plaignent d'avoir en gros du papier à
faire avant de avant d'appeler avant
d'appeler le juge quoi c'est-à-dire
10-20 quand je dis 10 c'est plutôt 20 ou
50 et effectivement je pense que cette
histoire de simplification
administrative elle est elle est
cruciale aujourd'hui quel que soit des
réformes qui seront qui seront menées
elle est cruciale parce qu'elle libérera
nous en tant que citoyen de quoi on a de
quoi on a besoin c'est que en fait on a
des policiers dans la rue qui qui
fassent des flagrants délits et qui qui
fasse la roue leur boulot c'est ça qu'on
a besoin c'est pas qu'ils soient
derrière l'ordinateur et c'est vrai que
là on les a au fur et à mesure des
années en fait on a on a érigé une
espèce de carcan et en gros bon ben moi
je comprends qu'il faille appeler un
médecin je comprends qu'il faille
appeler un avocat je comprends on
comprend tous je veux dire par rapport
aux libertés publiques on comprend qu'il
y a un certain nombre d'obligations le
problème c'est que ces obligations ont
pris quelque part le pas on écrasé le
métier et ça et ça ça fait perdre du
sens d'ailleurs au métier parce que ils
se disent bon ben ok moi si j'arrête un
voleur non je vais passer cinq ou six
heures au commissariat et j'ai peut-être
pas arrêté le voleur d'après c'est ça ce
futur ça c'est aussi c'est aussi le
policier concret que ça et voilà c'est
aussi concret que ça alors je voudrais
qu'on parle maintenant du taux
d'élucidation des des dossiers et je
vous propose d'écouter ce qu'on dit
Frédéric vaut le directeur général de la
police nationale qui était auditionné ce
matin même ici au Sénat
cette réforme est particulièrement
nécessaire pour la filière police
judiciaire confrontée à de grandes
difficultés
les causes de la crise que connaît cette
filière sont multiples dû notamment à
une complexification excessive et
toujours plus grande de la procédure
pénale et une politique des ressources
humaines peu adaptée aux spécificités de
ces métiers un certain nombre de ces
facteurs à contribuer à ce que la
filière investigation de la police
nationale soit malheureusement moins
efficace qu'elle n'a pu l'être dans le
passé sur la période de 2010-2019 les
taux d'élucination ont baissé de manière
constante et significative quel que soit
l'agrégat concernés atteinte au bien à
tête aux personnes ou délinquance
économiques et financière David lears
comment il s'explique ce chiffre cette
baisse du taux des lucidation alors
d'abord il y a un fait très simple je
l'ai dit à Éric Dupond-Moretti qui avait
reçu les syndicats de police dans le
cadre des états généraux de la justice
et d'ailleurs ça lui a pas plu mais
c'est une réalité c'est pas qu'une
perception depuis 30 ans toutes les
réformes de la procédure pénale ont été
au profit des auteurs les droits des
auteurs et pas au profit des victimes
qu'est-ce que c'est de réformer au
profit des victimes c'est de simplifier
le judiciaire pour savoir plus et pour
en faire plus pour mieux répondre aux
victimes ce qu'elle dit Frédéric Ploquin
ce que dit qu'à Michel une victime elle
peut comprendre qu'on ne trouve pas son
agresseur mais elle ne peut pas
comprendre qu'on ne lui dise pas où on
est son enquête aujourd'hui on est
saturé de dossier le vrai sujet
effectivement pour le judiciaire pour
l'investigation c'est la simplification
de la procédure pénale nous notre boulot
police c'est de mieux s'organiser pour
mieux le traiter pour ensuite mieux
libérer les effectifs dans la rue donc
ça c'est de l'organisation interne faut
pas se tromper de cible je vous l'ai dit
il faut bien organiser la PJ mais le
vrai sujet c'est la simplification
du taux de lucidation on comprend je
crois que les citoyens comprennent pas
rapidement de quoi il s'agisse ils sont
cambriolés ils ont envie qu'on arrête le
voleur c'est ça mais il faut quand même
dire qu'en matière de police judiciaire
et ça ça peut politiquement ça peut
gêner à un moment donné un ministre ou
un préfet le taux d'hélicitations des
affaires qui concernent le crime
organisé et c'est pas qu'il est plus bas
mais que les gens c'est que les enquêtes
sont beaucoup plus longues et ça il faut
l'accepter je veux dire le temps long de
l'enquête de la police judiciaire je
crois que n'importe quel ministre doit
le comprendre et l'accepter c'est pas du
résultat les médias c'est pas mal moi
prochain là les gars moi je veux ça je
veux tel camembert tel résultat
ses forces pour faire du chiffre et être
meilleur sur les sur la petite
délinquance du résultat politique
immédiat j'entends ça et le fait que le
travail en police judiciaire je veux
dire on dit oui alors il dit en bas de
chez moi mais on répond aux citoyens bah
oui mais vous savez pour arrêter
l'équipe qui dit en bas de chez vous on
peut effectivement arrêter sur le champ
faire un bâton et arrêter juste je
termine le guetteur mais si on veut
démanteler l'équipe laissez-nous six
mois alors et là les gens disent
attendez six mois et si pendant six mois
cette incompréhension je vais vous
donner la parole tout de suite je vous
le promets que Michel mais ça va
exactement dans le sens de ce que décrit
à l'instant à Frédéric Ploquin c'est le
témoignage de commissaire divisionnaire
de la police judiciaire de Montpellier
très inquiète pour justement la lutte
contre la criminalité organisée on
l'écoute
je suis très inquiète pour la société
française pour on va laisser à nos
enfants je vous promets que très très
court terme si on ne travaille plus sur
la criminalité organisée la France sera
complètement gangrenée par par une mafia
par le narco de banditisme
quotidiennement la PJ contre le narco
venditisme et si on ne travaille plus à
100 %
la France aura un bon grenier Camille
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez pardon lui
répondre à cette judiciaire son prénom
c'est Nathalie qui craint de perdre en
efficacité contre les gros trafics déjà
ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est qu'on va
pas muter d'office des enquêteurs de la
PJ dans d'autres secteurs les offices
centraux qui ont une grande expertise où
on perdurer en l'état donc voilà on va
pas changer tout ça et justement la
question des stupéfiants et pour moi
très intéressante et un exemple de ce
qu'on a réussi la réforme sur les
stupéfiants en France elle a réussi déjà
parce qu'il y a une commissaire à la
tête qui est exceptionnelle et
extrêmement dynamique mais elle a réussi
cette femme commissaire a vraiment du
haut vers le bas irrigué la police sur
cette question des stupéfiants c'est à
dire que à l'Office de la police
judiciaire on peut discuter avec les
homologues américains de la DEA à
l'international on est rassemblé même en
interministériel autour de cette offace
cette office stupéfiant qui fonctionne
extrêmement bien et en même temps cette
offace du haut de l'Office arrive à
avoir des liens directs avec les
territoires on a réussi à cartographier
les points de Deal avoir des réunions au
niveau départemental régional sur les
questions de stupéfiants en rassemblant
les acteurs justement sur les
stupéfiants séparés sans ce qui
fonctionne bien depuis quelques mois et
on peut tout à fait l'imaginer dans
plein d'autres domaines de la
criminalité organisée on peut du bas
jusqu'au plafond avoir une réelle chaîne
et des réels liens entre tous les
enquêteurs actuellement en sécurité
publique en police aux frontières ou en
police judiciaire et demain dans cette
filière police judiciaire investigation
qui sera créée alors il y a un autre
témoignage que je voudrais vous proposer
maintenant il nous reste à une douzaine
de minutes on va vraiment parler
maintenant de de ce que vous avez ok les
uns et les autres mais rapidement
le départementalisation de la de la
police en général et de la police
judiciaire en particulier on va écouter
le témoignage de François Molins comme
procureur général il a eu autorité sur
la police judiciaire pendant 40 ans et
c'est donc de quoi il parle et il
s'oppose lui à la réforme on écoute
cette réforme elle suscite à mon avis
à raison beaucoup d'inquiétudes parce
qu'elle est porteur d'un seul homme de
danger le premier effectivement c'est de
détruire quelque chose qui fonctionne
parce qu'aujourd'hui on manque d'OPJ il
y a plus de qualité dans les procédures
des commissariats les seuls services qui
sont arrivés à garder la qualité dans
les enquêtes c'est la PJ
le second risque c'est que effectivement
on peut s'interroger sur un département
la criminalité elle a beaucoup évolué ça
se joue aujourd'hui à l'échelle des
intérêts et de et de
l'international
donc il faut pas la faire en gros elle
est pas bonne
il y a les interférences effectivement
du politique il y aura une baisse de la
direction des enquêtes par les
magistrats qui ont moins de choix de
services enquêteurs bon alors il y a
plusieurs critiques il y en a une dont
on a déjà parlé donc il y a la gérance
politique on va y venir dans ce débat
mais sur le CET échelle départementale
de la nouvelle organisation qui me
reflète donc vous l'avez un peu évoqué
rapidement tout à l'heure je voudrais
savoir pourquoi ça suicide vos critiques
en tant que que magistrat
parce que on nous estimons que cette
échelle départementale n'est pas du tout
appropriée
aux affaires que nous avons à nous avons
à connaître et que au contraire il faut
une police qui puisse s'affranchir des
limites territoriales d'ailleurs c'était
l'origine la raison de la création de la
police judiciaire et en fait ce motif
demeure d'actualité enfin et toujours
très pertinent et voilà l'année
délinquance s'affranchit des limites
territoriales des départements et on a
besoin donc d'une police mobile et qui
ne soit pas limitée dans un territoire
qui est trop petit David Lebars votre
avis en détail sur sur la départementale
je vous l'ai dit dans d'autres termes il
y a des services de police qui ont
besoin d'être installés dans d'autres
échelles départementales par rapport à
la criminalité qui n'est pas enfermée
dans le département ça là-dessus on est
tous d'accord sur l'aspect politique moi
je suis un petit peu
sur le département c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui très clairement les enquêtes
principales de il y a beaucoup
d'enquêtes de la police judiciaire qui
ont bien au-delà d'un département et
bien d'accord
et de plus en plus est-ce que vous
diriez ça alors de plus en plus et en
même temps de plus en plus local aussi
il y a les deux il y a les deux un point
de vie de local qui fait 15000 € le jour
il a au dessus de lui un énorme
importateur qui alimente et vous voyez
c'est ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
celui qui vend au jour le jour et qui
pourrit la vie des habitants il est
alimenté par un trafiquant qui fait de
l'importation donc c'est beaucoup plus
nuancé que ça c'est très compliqué puis
il y a des nouvelles formes de
délinquance de toute façon je crois
qu'on partage un point tout ne rentre
pas l'échelle du département je vous dis
je l'avais dit au ministre c'est une
erreur sémantique et c'est une erreur
d'imaginer qu'on va la faire rentrer
comme ça parce qu'il y a des services
qui ont de la transversalité je rappelle
que les magistrats aussi ont choisi de
servir de choisir des services en
fonction de leurs besoins et en fonction
des nécessités de l'enquête y compris de
la confidentialité alors pour l'émission
je vais vous donner la parole juste
après mais j'ai cherché quel était le
département français qui avait le plus
de départements limitrophes et donc
c'est la Seine-et-Marne il y a 10
départements limitrophes de l'Aube à
l'Yonne en passant par l'Essonne ou la
ou la Seine-Saint-Denis je peux pas
croire que que en Seine-et-Marne on va
s'arrêter à la frontière de la
Seine-Saint-Denis ou de ou de l'Yonne
donc j'aimerais comprendre j'aimerais
comprendre mais pourquoi pourquoi
le mieux son bassin délinquance en fait
c'est là où autour du préfet on discute
des situations
de nouveaux silos départementaux pour
pour remplacer les silos qui étaient les
silos des services par exemple si on
prend la question des transports en
commun en Île-de-France il y a des
services départementaux mais qui
travaillent ensemble parce que par
définition le RER passe d'un département
à l'autre donc c'est des choses dont on
a l'habitude de le faire plutôt
effectivement en sécurité publique
actuellement un petit peu moins en
police judiciaire mais c'est quelque
chose qui est faisable qui fonctionne
bien de toute manière cet ancrage
territorial il est aussi important pour
nous parce qu'on a besoin de
déconcentrer les prises de décision on a
besoin que ce soit le terrain qui dirige
les besoins on a besoin que les chefs de
la police soit au plus près du terrain
c'est ce qu'on réclame depuis des
décennies que NATO entendu des des
gardiens de la paix des
officiers de police demander cette
proximité des chefs de la police avec le
terrain là on ramène le chef de la
police dans le département au plus près
des effectifs et nous ça nous semble
être aussi important en termes
managérial de rapprocher ainsi de
déconcentrer les prises de décision
c'est pas Paris qui décidera ça sera le
terrain et si le terrain a besoin des
compétences du département à côté de la
région de la zone de l'Office il pourra
l'activer mais il faudra le demander
sera peut-être un peu plus long pas
nécessairement les contacts ils vont
être établis et aussi par bassin et par
thématique je vous dis sur les
transports en commun par exemple ça
marche très bien il faudra le faire
selon les types de télélinquance selon
les frontières qui qui existent alors on
va parler du risque d'ingérence
politique et pour commencer Mathieu ben
on va faire un focus sur celui qui qui
est tout en haut de la hiérarchie
c'est-à-dire le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin un nouveau texte
polémique pour Gérard de Manin elle
croire qu'il les aime à croire qu'il les
recherche selon le vieil adège selon
lequel il y a pas de mauvaise publicité
il y a que de la publicité le ministre
de l'Intérieur depuis sa nomination à la
place vauvaux a beaucoup fait parler de
lui alors il faut reconnaître que de la
sécurité globale en passant par le
projet de loi séparatisme au niveau de
la sécurité les plusieurs policière et
même parfois la reprise active de faits
diversain occupe le terrain à l'image de
celui qui fut son mentor et qui
occupa lui aussi le ministère de
l'Intérieur et même s'en servir de
tremplin Nicolas Sarkozy de Nicolas
Sarkozy il a
hérité du goût de la formule qui choque
souvenez de quand j'entends le mot
violence policière personnellement je
mets tout ou je trouve Madame Le Pen un
peu branlante un peu molle même si elle
fait polémique tant que le débat autour
tourne autour de lui et comme Nicolas
Sarkozy il a parfois tendance à pousser
le bouchon un petit peu loin calmez-vous
madame ça va bien se passer sonner cette
petite phrase qu'il avait lancé à une
journaliste de l'ancien président il a
aussi retenu une leçon l'avait plus bleu
que bleu autrement dit coller aux
intérêts des policiers qui défend contre
vents et marées y compris quand certains
d'entre eux que la mer que le principal
problème de la police c'était la justice
fidélité aux hommes aussi parfois coûte
que coûte comme l'a montré son soutien
appuyé et répété au très controversé
préfet d'idées à la banque alors est-ce
qu'on est plus dans la com des mots où
est-ce qu'il y a des moyens
effectivement plutôt d'une bonne fenêtre
aboutir parce que depuis son élection en
2017 Emmanuel Macron a réinvesti dans la
police que ce soit dans les hommes ou
dans le matériel Gérald Darmanin s'en
est d'ailleurs félicité lundi lors de la
présentation du budget le budget 2023 du
ministère l'intérieur était historique
a-t-il écrit avec une hausse un milliard
de 150 millions d'euros et puis 3000
emplois créés dont 2874 policiers et
gendarme alors les esprits taquins ne
manqueront pas de souligner que le même
homme qui a su à la fois défendre et
porter la parole de Nicolas Sarkozy sous
le quinquennat duquel 10000 postes
avaient été supprimé peut tout aussi
bien se féliciter sous Emmanuel Macron
que ces postes soient recréés ça
s'appelle la politique et comme Nicolas
Sarkozy vise plus haut que la Place
Beauvau évidemment évidemment il fait
partie des trois poids lourds de la
macronie qui prétendent au plus hautes
ambitions avec Bruno Le Maire avec
Édouard Philippe avec une tactique
différente quand même bien à lui lui se
présente aux élections par exemple il a
fait pour les départements il a fait
pour les législatives qu'il a remporté
haut la main il fait ça un peu plus
classique à l'ancienne il a une autre
tactique aussi en homme d'appareils qui
connaît bien il s'intéresse beaucoup
parti présidentielle dont il va
superficier de la formation dans
l'espoir de le transformer il nous faut
un parti de masse Renaissance n'est pour
l'instant qu'un parti de bourgeois avec
quelques cadres a-t-il lâché dans un
dîner fin août devant Emmanuel Macron
selon une confidence rapportée par le
point ça n'est pas forcément plus au
président mais voilà Darmanin provoque
Darmanin
pèse et Darmanin pèse pèse et passe
entre les gouttes pardon la seule
question c'est jusqu'à quand et donc ça
ouvre ce dernier chapitre sur le la
question de la du poids de l'État ou de
l'ingérence politique dans les dans les
enquêtes de police judiciaire je
rappelle ce que disait François moulins
procureur général près de la Cour de
cassation dans l'extrait qu'on a entendu
tout à l'heure David le bar c'est est-ce
que c'est une crainte pour vous est-ce
que c'est quand même pas un fantasme
journalistique donc et est-ce que le
nouvel organisation peut renforcer ce
risque écoutez je vais retourner le
sujet en vous donnant un exemple qui
fonctionne la préfecture de police de
Paris est dirigée par un préfet en
dessous duquel il y a un directeur de la
police judiciaire parisienne est-ce
qu'il y a un sujet à Paris pour les
magistrats de saisir la PJ parisienne si
on a un il faut nous le dire ça veut
dire qui a un problème de corruption de
porosité et il faut le régler je crois
qu'il y en a pas tout comme quand on
saisit un service de gendarmerie on se
pose pas la question de savoir si le
gendarme son chef est tout pas en
contact avec un préfet de région un
préfet de département je trouve ce
plutôt vilain procès de le faire à la
police donc c'est pas parce qu'il y a un
préfet au niveau départemental ou
finalement au sommet de la hiérarchie
que il y aura plus de pression mais
parce qu'il y a des lois et que les
policiers sont respectueux des lois et
les lois sont très bien faites sur le
secret de l'enquête les potes de
procédure pénale est parfaitement claire
et si elles sont enfreintes il faut
punir et ça c'est la minorité
le principe intangible de séparation de
l'autorité judiciaire et de l'État et
moi je veux défendre les préfets de
départements qui ont bien d'autres chats
fouetter la politique de la ville la
relance l'ordre public et qui n'ont pas
du tout l'intention de s'ingérer dans
les affaires judiciaires pas sûr que Kim
reflète soit dans aussi optimiste ce que
vous qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
non nous ne sommes pas du tout aussi
optimiste et c'est vrai que cette
organisation en silo dont on a parlé
elle présente aussi l'avantage pour
l'autorité judiciaire de voilà d'avoir
un lien direct avec les enquêteurs de
police judiciaire qui rendent compte au
magistrats qui les mandatent et donc là
le fait de savoir que ces enquêteurs de
police judiciaires désormais seront sous
l'autorité du directeur départemental de
la police nationale en lien direct comme
on l'a dit avec le préfet voilà nous
nous inquiète énormément en termes de
remontées d'informations concrètement le
le préfet le ddpn aura un accès direct
et beaucoup plus facile aux
investigations menées donc j'entends
toutes les voilà les déclarations les
rassurantes et je ne doute pas de leur
sincérité mais après concrètement c'est
un moyen qui existera plus simple
d'accéder plus simplement aux
investigations ça nous incite
est-ce qu'il faut faire confiance au
texte existant à la Constitution comme
vous le dit ou est-ce qu'il faut que
dans cette réforme il y ait un garde-fou
supplémentaire alors 90% des enquêtes
actuellement sont réalisées par les
surtés urbaines qui dépend du
direct public qui rencontre toutes les
semaines au préfet donc en fait 90 % des
enquêtes c'est déjà le cas et pour qu'il
n'y ait pas l'ombre d'un doute on a
décidé que tout ce qui est ressortait de
de des infractions liées à la probité ce
serait placé un niveau supra
départemental pour que personne puisse
nous taxer du moindre doute sur une
connivence entre un pouvoir
administratif et les enquêteurs donc
voilà je pense c'est vraiment un faux
procès je pense qu'il y a un imaginaire
collectif et une un mythe autour de tout
cela et je trouve que c'est assez des
ministres se tient pas au courant quand
une affaire sensible touche un
adversaire politique etc on parle des
préfets est-ce que vous croyez que les
préfets sur la demande du ministre en
tout cas c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
pour 90% des enquêtes de sûreté
80 dans 99% des cas ça ne posera pas de
problème il veut quand même rappeler que
dans ce petit pourcent il y a parfois
des enquêtes de la police judiciaire qui
dérange le pouvoir en place ça me paraît
clair notamment dans les affaires de de
corruption politique ou financière et là
on verra on verra
au niveau national sur ce 1% qui il y a
des affaires qui peuvent déranger un
ministre de l'Intérieur directement
pourquoi pas un président de la
République etc aujourd'hui justement
c'est ces affaires là qui apparemment
inquiète les magistrats aujourd'hui je
pense aussi qu'il faut pas présenter la
police judiciaire comme une police
récalcitrante à la réforme elle a réussi
par le passé à se transformer à ce
moderniser à passer dans le cyber là on
va mener ensemble et le directeur de la
police est vraiment à l'écoute et fait
un travail de de conviction et mouiller
la chemise finalement pour pour pour
réformer tout cela il faut aussi que la
police judiciaire prenne les
opportunités de transformation et
parviennent à se moderniser et en face
bénéficier toute la police et les autres
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
débat Frédéric flocage rappelle le titre
de votre livre c'était la PJ le temps
béni des flics publiés aux éditions
voilà je vous donne rendez-vous demain
18h 22h pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public et puis ne ratez pas demain matin
bonjour chez vous rien Mancini reçoit
Frédéric Valtou le maire de
Fontainebleau porte-parole d'horizon et
président de la Fédération hospitalière
de France belle soirée à toutes et à
tous
[Musique]